[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben dieses video habe ich
euch schon lange versprochen denn ich
habe zu euch gesagt ich nehme euch mal
mit in einen türkischen supermarkt wir
sind hier in bochum foto pia hier bin
ich selber auch stammkunden und ich
nehme ich jetzt einfach mal durch die
gänge
bevor wir aber rein gehen springen wir
einmal kurz zurück zum großhändler wo
die ware herkommt und dann zeige ich
euch wie es darin aussehen was sie dort
alles zu kaufen kriegt
bevor wir jetzt zum großen kirchen von
haftung zwischenstopp in meiner
heimatstadt
die auch total gerne und möchte ich ganz
kurz erklären warum ich dieses video
überhaupt macht den film eine rezepte
gerade jetzt wenn man dann reihe sind
wir ganz aus dem türkischen oder
arabischen supermarkt und da sahen ihren
ein rezept nicht nachmachen denn ich hab
keinen zugang es kann kein türkisch oder
arabisch und dann besteht einfach sein
dass es nicht einfach sein und lasst
euch überraschen von den fußball so ihr
lieben hier befinden uns gerade im
orientalischen großmarkt und dieser
liefert auch nach kappadokien
anschließend aus und das ist ein ganz
besonderer großmarkt denn hier hat der
hase sein einjähriges gelenk das
praktikum gemacht und besser ganz
besonders ist und die stimmt hier am
eingang auch genau richtig das sind die
dattel nennen die haben vor ramadan
hochsaison und werden ohne ende verkauft
[Musik]
was ja auch zu finden ist wenn zum
beispiel madelein sie sind ganz typisch
bei den marokkanern und die werden gerne
mit marokkanischem grünem tee getrunken
was auch super cool ist ist diese
handgemachte naturseifen und zwar
besteht die aus oliven lorbeer und
schwarzkümmelöl und ich wünsche dir
könnte das riechen das riecht so
angenehm
[Musik]
hier findet ihr auch bagger war von
qualität und das wird mit butter gemacht
dazu erzähle ich euch gleich bei
kappadokien noch was
[Musik]
und das wirklich toll wir sind auch
jetzt schon großhandel ist das hier
wirklich wahre aus aller welt kommt aus
tunesien aus thailand aus marokko aus
frankreich und der hauser ist wieder nur
am naschen
wusstet ihr übrigens dass es dattel
sirup gibt das manchmal mit wasser und
ist gerade einmal dame sehr beliebt und
dann muss man da noch ein paar nüsse
rein und trinkt das zum beispiel abends
zum star
[Musik]
viele von euch haben mich auch gefragt
ob ich denn mal honoriert zubereiten
kann es macht natürlich gerne und zwar
sind das muss kraut blätter die sind
total gesund und wusstet ihr dass früher
nur die pharaonen davon essen durften
das heißt es folgt dürfte das gar nicht
essen weil es quasi ein königs essen war
ich ihm das direkt mal mitte mache ich
das gerne mal ein rezept zu
[Musik]
jetzt befinden wir uns gerade im
kühlhaus des orientalischen supermarkt
und hab ich den händen grillkäse
halloumi ist unglaublich lecker probiert
ihn gerne mal aus während des grillens
oder auch gern mal auf einem sandwich
[Musik]
jeder von euch kennt wahrscheinlich
tiere und das ist so diese stadtgröße
diese im deutschen supermarkt geht hier
im orientalischen bereich ist das ein
bisschen anders denn schaut mal wir
haben sogar 500 gramm dosen und was ich
auch mega cool finde gerade für die kids
kiri die pds ich sogar gerne schreibt er
nämlich über ein von mit
in der türkei sind wir ganz bekannt für
unsere sonnenblumenkerne und im
arabischen raum ist etwas anders da sind
es um honig millionen kerne kürbiskerne
und melonen kern hansa das auch mein
kelly tippi
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr gesehen wo die ware unter
anderem herkommen ich will euch gar
nicht weiter auf die folter spannen
lassen uns direkt mal reingehen und hier
gehts direkt schon los mit den
hülsenfrüchten ganz typisch sind die
kichererbsen hier sehen wir auch weiter
herzen
ich zeige euch übrigens nicht nur die
typischen lebensmittel aus dem
türkischen geschäft sondern auch die
haushaltswaren zum beispiel hier zum
reinigen aber das ist gleich mittel und
das hat jeder türkische frau zu hause
was auch total typisch ist es diese
seife hier die tut der haut supergut
jetzt gehen wir aber mehr weiter auf die
linke seite
denn ihr habt es wahrscheinlich so im
deutschen supermarkt nicht gesehen aber
schaut euch mal diese wollte ich an das
ist alles paprika und im türkischen ist
es so dass man wirklich dieses paprika
mark oder tomatenmark in fast alle
speisen mit reingeht deswegen gibt es
die auch in so großen eimern zu kaufen
hier zum beispiel das sind 4000 350
gramm
ganz typisch für die orientalische küche
ist natürlich oliven und olivenöl kommt
überall rein
und hier haben wir so viele verschiedene
sorten hier steht sogar extra drauf für
kalte speisen für warme speisen und die
sind natürlich alle auch kalt gepresst
was auch total interessant ist es gibt
so viele oliven varianten die sind
gefüllt nicht gefüllt dann gibt's
verschiedene größen
es gibt oliven für verschiedene
tageszeiten
[Musik]
wenn es eine sache in der türkischen
küche oder orientalischen küche gibt die
ganz typisch ist dann ist es joghurt und
ab dann gibt es jede menge 1000
verschiedenen vorführungen und wir
machen sogar so dass wir zu warmen
speisen vor allem zu kebab speisen oder
auch mal zu nudeln einfach mal joghurt
essen das ist uns erstmals der welt und
ganz normal ist auch dass dem türkischen
supermarkt alles ohne gelatine ist
die größe ist wahrscheinlich die art von
fetakäse die ihr aus dem deutschen
supermarkt kennt hier ist es ein
bisschen anders hier haben wir andere
größen und zwar hier
die 800 gramm dürfen ohne aber auch hier
wer nicht so viel mag die 500 gramm dose
gerade waren wir noch im großmarkt und
haben diese produkte gesehen und jetzt
sind sie hier schon im regal einsortiert
außerdem wollte ich euch hier noch
dieses produkt zeigen
davon habe ich euch ja gerade schon
berichtet und das gibt es eben nur hier
und deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir
eben den zugang haben zum türkischen
supermarkt weil es uns würde ich hier
gar nicht drankommen
kommen wir zu einem weiteren sehr
wichtigen produkt in der orientalischen
welt und zwar ist das purer
butterschmalz leute die zum beispiel
keine butter vertragen können die
sollten lieber zur butterschmalz greifen
das hat total viele positive
eigenschaften und das macht man nicht
nur in sülz zu spalten sondern auch in
herzhafte
jetzt stehe ich hier gerade vor dem
wurst regal und das ist so vielfältig
und groß schaut euch mal die ganzen
sorten an
die haben wir total flügel alles
mögliche und was auch total toll ist
hier gibt es ganze jahr über
grillwürstchen
denn im orientalischen ist es so dass
man diese gremien tatsächlich das ganze
jahr über ist als gerne auch mal zum
frühstück und zum abendessen in
deutschen supermärkten ist zurück
nämlich die berühmte knoblauch wo ist
bereits etabliert aber ich glaube es
gibt nirgendwo so eine riesen auswahl
wie hier
eine der bekanntesten türkischen
süßspeisen ist wackler und hier findet
ihr eben auch den baklava teig den kann
man natürlich auch herzhafte legen das
habe ich euch ja in einem video bereits
gezeigt es folgen noch viele weitere
und hier sehen wir auch das türkische
kaffee hier für kinder das ist dieses
engelshaar und das findet ihr eben auch
meistens nur in diesen supermärkten
hallo guten tag ich gerne lange schulter
wenn es geht ohne knochen bitte danke
schön
nur noch ein bisschen fleisch ganz gerne
etwas fleisch lassen
ja ich hätte gern noch 500 gramm
fettarmes rinderhack bitte das wäre es
vielen schönen tag auch so danke und
dass es eben der vorteil in türkischen
supermärkten ist der metzger schon
integriert und das sind eben richtige
gelernte metzger hinter der theke die am
alles vorbereiten sondern habt ihr
zuhause einfach viel weniger arbeit
und was doch ganz typisch ist für
türkische supermärkte oder auch
orientalischen supermärkte an sich sind
haushaltswaren hier gibt es wirklich die
gläser geschirr gläser und auch
teekannen und was ich auch total genial
finde ist dieses auch java damit könnt
ihr euren teig hauchdünn ausrollen und
den kriegt ihr auch hier und das ganze
auch sehr preiswert außerdem gibt's ja
auch diese speziellen form für knöpfe
also für knöpfe und die für mich eben
genial da könnt ihr die nämlich
portionsweise backen
[Musik]
ein witziges gadget ist zum beispiel
dieses viertel und damit könnt ihr
einfach den boden reinigen einfach hin
und herschieben und das fängt euren
schmutz auf und das ist übrigens haben
dass persönliches lieblingsgerät zu
hause vor dem gewürzregal könnte ich
stunden verbringen hier gibt es so viele
gehört zunächst woanders einfach nicht
gibt und meistens braucht man eben genau
diese gewürze geben euch mal als
beispiel haben wir seltsamen hier ein
bisschen weiter ganz schöne kümmel
sorten und was ich total genial finde
ist zumal er sich baum gewürz und kommt
auch in ganz vielen orientalischen
speisen rein
die türkische und orientalische küche
ist bekannt dafür dass sie mir ganzen
mit teigwaren machen und vor allem mit
ludger und ich nehme mir jetzt auch ein
paket mit und daraus machen wir gleich
das schön
[Musik]
okay ihr lieben es wird ernst wir stehen
kurz vorm fastenmonat ramadan und das
wichtigste im ramadan sind die daten und
hier gibts total viele verschiedene aus
tunesien aus den emiraten und aus saudi
arabien
[Musik]
in der orientalischen küche wird als
beilage vieler reis gegessen als nudeln
oder kartoffeln und hier gibts auch
total viele varianten josef martinz
buchpreis also alles was das herz
begehrt
in kanada werden diese fünf kilo reis
und verkauft und auch zu einem
günstigeren preis denn ihr wisst ja
normal sein wird ganz viel reis gegessen
[Musik]
neben ganz vielen verschiedenen
eissorten sind weiter und linsen auch
total wichtig in der orientalischen
küche und dürfen nicht fehlen
und hier zeigen wir euch mal eine kleine
auswahl
jetzt stehe ich hier gerade beim obst
und da vorne ist auch die
gemüseabteilung und viel findet man
einfach total frisches obst und gemüse
weil das jede nacht frisch geholt wird
vom großhändler
man hat einfach diese qualität wie vom
frisch max
[Musik]
wassermelonen sind gerade anderer mann
total wichtig weil sie sehr viel wasser
enthalten und in kombination mit
schafskäse
klingt verrückt aber total lecker
[Musik]
jetzt befinden wir uns gerade in der
süßwarenabteilung und hier finde ich
mich total wohl
ich habe dort auch viele liebling
süßigkeiten was ist in eurem süßigkeit
schreibt es mir gerne in die kommentare
ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal was es hier
alles gibt
[Musik]
in meinen orientalischen rezepten schwer
mich total von rosen und orangenblüten
wasser und das findet ihr eben hier wo
auch sonst
das bemühen der küche nie fehlen darf
ist granatapfel zero probiert gerne mal
im salat aus ich nehme mir jetzt auch
mal eine flasche mit und zeigt euch dann
nicht das zu hause zubereitet in die
abteilung für brotaufstriche haben wir
das typische überhaupt nämlich termine
das ist sesampaste und wird auch gerne
mit trauben sirup gemischt ergibt eine
richtig leckere masse und hier unten
haben wir auch noch hell war das ist
auch ganz typisch helfer wer zu 50
prozent aus sesampaste hergestellt das
ganz typisch mann ist es mit brot oder
auch einfach so mit der gabel und ganz
typisch ist auch dass pistazien ohne
ende enthalten sind
direkt neben dem helfer haben wir hier
richtig schön honig und zwar waren honig
den findet man so auch ganz selten in
den anderen zu vermerken
diese geflügelfleisch groß ist ganz
typisch das ist eine ganz typische
frühstücks wusste gibt es einmal in
diesen großen format oder aber auch wie
für mich gemacht in so einem kleineren
format
[Musik]
falls mal besuch ansteht oder auch ganz
typisch auf hochzeiten gibt es
verschiedene müsse und die findet ihr
ebenfalls hier
[Musik]
vor und während mama dann herrscht hier
hochbetrieb sowie bei christen zum
beispiel an weihnachten total viel los
ist so viel während ramadan
so wie es in deutschen supermärkten
fertigmischungen für königsberger klopse
und und und gibt so gibt es eben hierfür
köpfte
[Musik]
in einem orientalischen supermarkt gibt
es viele viele sachen wenn ich euch
alles zeigen würde wird das video fünf
stunden lang dauern ich zeige euch hier
nur so die kleinen feinheiten aber ihr
müsst natürlich selber rausfinden was
für euch ja am besten ist und was auch
für euren geschmack passt also traut
euch rein und gehen einfach mein sohn
vor max haller gp halle amine
13 fast auch nicht hinterher habe ich
mit dankeschön
danke gleichfalls
so ich geh jetzt meinen einkäufen nach
hause und zwar was schönes kleines ich
bin total froh dass ich hier drehen
durfte denn wir sind sehr gerne über
kappadokien genauso wie über den
deutschen supermärkten gibt es halt eben
die die etwas besser sortiert sind und
die die nicht so gut sortiert sind
katalog ist definitiv eines meiner
lieblings supermärkte den gibt es
nämlich in bochum auch in meiner
heimatstadt herne und jetzt geben wir zu
mir in die küche
[Musik]
das sind die leckereien die ich aus
meinem heutigen einkauf gezaubert habe
es gibt eine million möglichkeiten und
das video wird mich auch speziell
denjenigen die gesagt haben
klicke ich kann mein rezept den ich
immer nach machen weil du oft sachen aus
dem arabischen oder türkischen
supermarkt verwendet also ihr seht ihr
könnt einfach dort einkaufen die
vielfalt ist groß und ein an der stelle
möchte ich euch auch noch ganz kurz an
meine anstehende damals eine reihe
erinnern denn da kaufe ich auch viel aus
dem supermarkt ein und ihr werdet hin
und wieder dort auch mal hingehen müssen
auf kurz oder lang kommt ihr nicht dran
vorbei
ich möchte mich auch noch ganz herzlich
bedanken weil papa doc ja dass wir dort
filmen durften das war super so verliebt
vielen dank und auch noch mal ein großes
dankeschön an teuren photovoltaik dessen
kirchen dass wir dort im großhandel auch
nochmals nehmen durften
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr meinen
kanal abonniert damit ihr kein video
mehr verpasst und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal auf dieses kitchen
wird sein ob das sagen haben sie ich bin
der könig der welt
ja ich bin der könig der welt
[Musik]
okay okay